I'm gonna start by asking my panelists a
question here would you say you're more
like a bird a cat or a dog dog dog dog
dog I also would have said dog the
reason I'm asking this question is
because sex stamps are the new thing
that are happening at sex parties and
you put a stamp on you which basically
says what sort of sexual stuff you're
into what you're okay with people
approaching you with if you want to stop
the world yeah sex party sex parties
that's what the young thing
then the young people are having sex
parties we've got more info for you what
so yeah there here's what the sex stamps
look like so you can get a bird you get
a dog you can get a cat and you can put
them all over your body so that when
you're at one of these sex parties the
people basically can decide what they're
gonna do if you need to be given consent
before they do something or if you don't
want consent or you wanted a little
rougher or whatever it is so here's some
more info for you the second base
makeout party is part of a communicative
consensual movement helping to create
more structure in the world of intimate
often sexual parties because of the
slightly taboo nature of these parties
and the range of interests they indulge
in consent is an evolving tool in
ensuring safe fun and attracting new
participants I am NOT interested in
helping or offering my opinion on people
who go to sex parties like this is not a
thing that is happening all right
believe it
57 kids have gone to a sex party they
should be very careful and people should
be treated respectfully this is not a
thing that's happening in America it's
never happened it certainly didn't
happen between in the 1980s I'll tell
you right now somebody somebody never
got invited to a sex party have you been
and you go into a sec a CRT I don't sex
party where people were just having sex
yes never no of course not because
there's never been one there Jimmy never
been one Jimmy you were a comedian that
started in the late 80s there were sex
parties first of all I still think
there's a chance I might be President so
I'm not answering president of what of
anything yeah I have been to quasi sex
parties but what's with the new--this
stamps so they put a tattoo so if you
sew one of them the bird means you want
to be left off you know you really want
to be don't approach that person they'll
approach you they all have different
meanings so that you know
a dog I have to be a little more
aggressive this way 99.97% have never
been invited to a sex party I've never
heard of a sex party that are mortified
that their child alright never got
invited to a sex party I've got a little
more info on these parties at this
makeout party those who say they are
dogs here we go for the specific info
for you okay indicate that they are open
to being approached and touched cats
must be asked before things are
initiated birds are the most selective
in choosing and do not welcome direct
advances but animals are free to evolve
so you could have to when people can
figure out anyway if you have no you
stay away from that guy yeah do not get
moved on anything Ranga tank cause he'll
hurl [ __ ] at you do you think this takes
the fun out like we live in such an over
I got it I got it I got it we live in
such like over-regulated like nobody
wants to offend theirs I take the fun
out of a sex boy yeah you don't even
believe sex parties exist
I was really regular at a sex party you
know I was gonna invite you guys over
for a sex party this weekend there now
I'm not inviting you anymore because you
said you want to come I would love
coming of course all right I give up sex
parties are you having them are you
having group sex right now you got a
bird or a dog or a cat on you let us
know in the comments right down below